hi I'm kurtwood Smith and I play Red I'm
Deborah Joe Ruff I play kitty Foreman
what's up I'm Miss Cornell and I play
Jake helsa I'm Ren Dory and I play Ozzy
hi I'm Max and I play Nate hi my name is
Ashley afterhad and I play Gwen hey I'm
Sam Morelos and I play Nikki and hi I'm
Cali hoverda and I play Leia and we are
the cast of that 90s show and we're here
with BuzzFeed to figure out what
original character we are the character
that I think is most that I'm most like
is that kind of what it is no we're
gonna take a test okay
thank you
pick a song to sing a karaoke Bohemian
Rhapsody by Queen Wannabe by the Spice
Girls as it was by Harry Styles about
damn time by lizzo Living on a Prayer by
Bon Jovi karaoke pass I don't know any
of these songs except for Bohemian
Rhapsody you know Living on a Prayer
sing a little bit I'm not singing okay
I'm going to pick Bohemian Rhapsody
because they say mama and because I love
that song More Than Life more than life
well almost I have to pick Bohemian
Rhapsody I'm obsessed with Queen I also
learned that entire song and I was like
nine like me and my cousins performed it
for our parents that's such a realistic
things
I'm skipping karaoke
I don't karaoke I'll do Liz all about it
I knew you were gonna figure
when I'm in hair makeup mine plays it
for us for me actually amazed what about
you I'm respectfully passing
everyone's so predictable seriously
choose a movie that came out in the 70s
to watch tonight Star Wars A New Hope
Jaws The Godfather Greece Rocky Harry
I'm going to pick Rocky I liked Rocky
Star Wars A New Hope came out in the 70s
that's a movie that came on not all
these movies came out in the 70s yeah
they did no they didn't
yeah I think they did I think I'm going
to choose Kerry just because horror
classic I'm torn between the Godfather
and Rocky because I really love a good
boxing movie for some reason I don't
know I have to say The Godfather I'm
feeling Greece
I'm in a horror mood tonight I think I'm
either doing Jaws or Carrie you know
what I've heard of all these but I
haven't watched any oh that's okay so
which one okay
okay are we doing a Jaws movie night
then I'm sorry man I'm watching Carrie
tonight oh God wait we need to have a
double feature jaws and carrots you're
spending the summer in Point Place which
location are you excited to visit the
water tower The Hub the Foreman's
basement the photo Hut the Foreman's
driveway grooves record store and I'm
going to say the Hub because it has
french fries
I'm going to say the water tower because
it has a nice view I'm going with the
record store yeah this is so cool come
on
basement but then I
couch is so squishy uh I'm going with
the hot just because
you're sitting in a circle and the
Foreman's basement what are you snacking
on potato chips chocolate chip cookies a
slice of pizza candy popcorn
cheeseburger and fries I'm in the
basement in the circle I'm having
chocolate chip cookies I'm gonna say
cheeseburger and fries because it's the
biggest thing here if it said a whole
pizza I would have picked that but it
only says a slice so I'm going for
cheeseburger and fries what kind of
potato chips is the question I'm a salty
picture do they see something oh it's so
good I think you can pick any any
believer pickles flavored potatoes
pickled flavored wait is it like a
random flavored potato chip or do you
get to pick what I think banana I think
I have to go with potato chips we want
chocolate chip cookies I feel like this
depends on my mood I feel like right now
though I could go for some candy but I
normally wouldn't pick that I feel like
I would normally have cheeseburger and
fries candy 100 I know but I chose candy
Pizza yeah same here call it the slice
choose an actor who guest starred on
That 70s Show Dwayne Johnson Amy Adams
Tommy Chong Betty White Joseph
Gordon-Levitt Mary Tyler Moore Dwayne
Johnson
[Applause]
wait wait Dwayne Johnson's dad was
playing by Dwayne Johnson yes
very tough between two I'm gonna go for
beloved Betty White I'll choose Tommy
Chong I love Tommy Johnson
we're not just doing a unanimous Tommy
Tom oh you've met Tommy I know I like
talking yeah
all in favor of Tommy Chong say I I I
pick a show with an iconic friend group
that you would love to be part of
friends stranger things The Golden Girls
The Big Bang Theory new girl Parks and
Rec Parks and Rec and I'm gonna go with
stranger things because I like them New
Girl New Girl all the way I love new
girls so much I've binged that show up
I'm picking Golden Girls yeah
oh my God who are you I I'm nobody it
does yeah you didn't do it
all got Eric Foreman both Eric Foreman
Eric Foreman your personality matches
Eric you are passionate sensitive and a
little nerdy like Eric the best days for
you are when you're just hanging out
with your friends true you're extremely
passionate about the things you love
most in the world whether it's your
favorite movie or your first love that
sounds like me
oh that's actually lovely that fits him
and that's lovely and I don't mind being
Eric okay
thanks your personality match
you are devoted
voted Patty
you are someone who loves people whether
you're helping your friends or meeting a
new person you can easily make friends
with anyone wow you're considered the
mom of you is that true do we really
have a mom I don't think there is either
of us are like Karen figures
and be sure to watch that 90s show or
I'll put my foot in your ass there you
go
foreign
[Music]